That was awesome.
>> I know. The reason that we showed you guys, the
example of a Porsche to illustrate use, good user experience design.
Is because we want to explain that, good user experience should
make your users happy, it should make you happy. That's kind of
the whole point. And UX design is about all of these
tons of different things coming together. So if every person that
made the Porsche if anyone dropped the ball, the UX of
the Porsche wouldn't be awesome. It's, it's all these things coming together
that really makes user experience
design, because design is everyone's responsibility.
>> No, exactly, and I think one of the
important things for, for us as developers to remember
is that, all the things that made that Porsche
amazing, can actually port it directly into the software world.
>> Yeah.
>> So let's bring it from the Porsche world,
into the software world. Now, when we're in the software
world, as developers, we think in terms of code. So,
let's look at all the code that we write as
something that goes in this box, and let's say that all
the code, contributes to what's called the user experience, of a particular
application. So now if you, take a little bit closer look at
the chunks of code that we write. Let's say that you have
code, that essentially puts pixels on a screen or interacts with the
user in any way. This could be through audio input or audio
output. Let's say that that is your UI code. Let's say the
rest of the code that you write, stuff for your backend and
so on, the non-visual code, that actually does not
have an impact on the UI, but it does
have a direct and strong impact on the UX.
And that's something that, we should always keep in mind.
>> So, this is basically the difference between
UI and UX. They're not synonyms, but they
get thrown around a lot so I think
it's important to kind of, disambiguate these two terms.
>> Yeah, exactly. The visual and non-visual code come together
to deliver the user experience for your application, whereas
the visual code almost exclusively delivers the user interface.
>> But the most important thing is that
he overall UX, should make your users feel happy.
>> Yeah, so think about an applications that's made
you happy. What has blown your mind by delivering
an awesome user experience? Keep that app in mind,
because we're going to be using that later on this lesson.